qué daños se reportan por la tormenta
además que se espera para los próximos
días
muy buenos días angela desde nueva york
como decía es la tormenta henry tocó
tierra a más de 100 kilómetros a menos
de 100 kilómetros de aquí continúa
avanzando lentamente hacia el oeste por
con ética pero su paso afectará a 40
millones de personas y ha dejado ya a
más de 130 mil personas desde nueva york
hasta maine sin electricidad las
empresas dicen que podrían tardar hasta
14 días en restaurar ese sistema
eléctrico porque la situación es
complicada aquí en nueva york como veis
continúa lloviendo lo hace desde ayer
por la mañana y lo seguirá haciendo
durante todo el día eso está provocando
inundaciones en algunas estaciones de
metro lo que está haciendo que se
complica un poquito la rutina diaria
aquí en la gran manzana por eso nueva
york sigue bajo estado de emergencia el
presidente yoga y deán además ya dijo
ayer que mandaría a la ayuda federal tan
pronto como fuera posible porque hay
peligro también en las zonas costeras
por esas precipitaciones que se esperan
porque aunque como decía es la tormenta
jorge henry se ha ralentizado todavía
viene cargada de fuertes lluvias y
vientos que están provocando el corte de
carreteras
en nueva york y en new yersey
precisamente en este último estado ha
habido al menos 300 accidentes
automovilísticos y más de 290 personas
han llamado a los servicios de
emergencia pidiendo ayudas porque se
habían quedado atrapadas en sus
automóviles o en sus casas